there are some here particularly in
London who see the dep as an odd Bunch
who they can't really understand perhaps
that's because they haven't taken the
time to understand them and that all
flows for the confidence and Supply
agreement as well when the dup which I
was leading at the time a female
Anglican that has to be said but yet I
was caricatured in a very particular way
so there is a need for more
understanding as to what the dep wants
for the people of Northern Ireland as
British citizens living in Northern
Ireland and I think if people took the
time they would find that there is a
willingness to form the evolution again
they want to have the evolution again
they've always been a demolitionist
party and to do that however they need
to have the text in the proper way so
that we're protecting the citizens of
Northern Ireland as members of the
United Kingdom